welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Marvel Studios arched villain
of the next era Kang the Conqueror
presents a new Gambit in the trailer for
Ant-Man and the Wasps quantumania
telling Scott Lang I've been getting
if you help me so what's it gonna be I
honestly think Scott is just surprised
someone got his name right but help King
with what the d23 version of this
trailer went into more detail as Kang
tells Scott that he is just a man who
has lost a lot of time like you but we
can help each other with that someone
stole something from me and you're the
only one who can steal it back this
trailer suggests it was Janet Van Dyne
who stole this mystery item from Kang we
see what I assume to be Janet on a
Quantum realm Farm as his ship crashes
into this realm a few pieces of debris
break off and fade Janet seemed
especially terrified about Cassie
opening that channel to the quantum
realm and another part of the trailer
Hope asks Janet what she's so afraid of
and Janet responds there's something I
never told you now I have speculated a
thing that Kane could have lost would it
be his long-lost love rivona rensslayer
his lover from the comics and why would
they name the judge in Loki we're going
to rensslayer if they didn't plan to
connect her to Kang at some point but
based on the way Kang's ship breaks
apart maybe Janet stole a piece of
technology that allows his vessel to
function like a fuel source or a battery
or a converter or whatever powered his
original temp pad which might explain
why it looks so fractured in Loki now of
course I also speculated
what is she knocking oh my God every
time or should I say for all time always
miss minutes the mascot of the time
barriers Authority has some deeper
darker significance that Loki season 1
did not get to Tara Strong is returning
in season two and it suggested that
we're going to learn more about her
Secrets like what is she she artificial
intelligence is she someone's soul is
she magic or is she technology now my
theory is that Miss minutes is the
living embodiment of all of Ken's
temporal technology so that he doesn't
have to keep it in his head like a
backup Drive where he can store all of
his memories of his alternate timelines
to download whenever he reboots or
responds kind of like the cloud to your
new Apple device but there's only one
missed minutes and the King to possess
her wears the crown because he has the
most information about the Multiverse I
mean this gang trapped in the quantum
realm is clearly disoriented in the
Comic-Con in the d23 footage Kang asks
Scott you're an Avenger have I killed
you before our man doesn't remember [ __ ]
and in addition to cataloging his
memories I think Miss minutes also
served as this Kang's Quantum Navigator
the way he could pilot in and out of
different timelines in history and keep
track of what he changed in the process
really the keeper of his sacred timeline
because remember in the quantum realm
navigation is everything anyone with
pimtech can access the quantum realm but
it wasn't until Tony Stark unlocked the
secrets of time travel with that
inverted Mobius strip in Avengers end
game that the Avengers finally had a way
to actually use the quantum Realms time
vortexes Tony Stark made the first
discovery on the path that in the 31st
Century Nathaniel Richards would later
master in endgame it really was that
Quantum navigation risk Tech that Tony
provided that made all the difference
and how fitting is it that he remains
also wears his temp pad on the back of
his hand it's all connected so if this
gang had lost Miss minutes it would make
her up for grabs for some other Kang
like he who remains to recover that
fumble and use her to rewrite his own
sacred timeline now next
excuse me I need to wake up oh look at
that just brewed some fresh Trade coffee
that it got delivered Trade coffee is a
coffee subscription service that makes
it so simple for you to discover new
copies and make your best cup of coffee
at home every day no fancy equipment
required if you're a coffee person you
gotta get on the Trade coffee train
trade makes it super easy to get the
best coffee delivered fresh from the
finest local Roasters around the country
trade partners with the nation's top
rated independent roasters so you can
get great coffee while supporting small
local businesses it's a win-win whether
you already know what you like or are
new to Specialty coffee and need some
help trade makes being or becoming a
coffee person easy they'll send you
ground coffee or whole beans or however
you make your coffee at home I like
getting the coffee already ground so I
can just put a couple Scoops in my
French press and get going this month
trade sent me a few copies including
funky chicken from Red Rooster coffee
which has this earthy sweetness that I
just really like whether you're just
getting started or a coffee Aficionado
looking to discover something new trade
guarantees do you love your first bag or
they'll send you a new one for free
upgrade your coffee today with Trade
coffee and let them take the guesswork
out of finding your perfect cup right
now trade is offering our listeners a
total of 30 off your subscription plus
free shipping at drinktrade.com new
rockstars that's stringtrade.com for 30
off your subscription to the best
coffees in the country now I know I am
describing a scenario where Miss minutes
would have to have some corporeal form
that Janet could steal and for the TVA
and he remained Citadel to exist within
or be accessible from the quantum realm
those are both pretty big assumptions
but the truth is we do not know where
the TVA is in the comics the TBA is
located within the null time zone first
introduced in Fantastic Four 353 in 1991
this issue laid out the TBA the Chrono
monitors the various justices and the
Hall of chronometry but neither the null
time zone nor the tva's location MCU has
ever identified in the Loki series all
we know is that it's some Zone removed
from time or any sacred timeline with
these time doors that lead to any time
in any location in the history of the
Sacred timeline yet the TVA is also
affected the way universes are supposed
to be like after Sylvie stabs he remains
Loki finds herself in a new TDA that has
been worked by that event now ruled by a
more outwardly facing gang Could That Be
The Same Gang we're now meeting in
quantumania in the quantum realm Kang
lording over this TVA I mean a popular
Theory since the early days of Loki
season 1 is that the TVA could be
located within the quantum realm while
you could imagine some of that interior
design of the TVA existing inside of one
of the structures in hang City in this
Quantum Mania trailer I do not think the
TVA could exist in the quantum realm
without some barrier because time in the
quantum realm progresses as it does in
the surface realm that's why Janet Van
Dyne continued to age normally over the
30 years she was down there and to be
clear the reason Scott Lang experienced
five years as five hours to him is that
he went into a Time Vortex which is a
separate thing than the rest of the
quantum realm and we'll be clear that up
until the day I die it's probably my
most asked question but since the TVA
does not experience time at all like
Mobius never ages the whole place is
timeless it must be in a different Zone
than the quantum realm is in now it is
possible that the TVA is one layer
deeper than the quantum realm or since
the quantum realm isn't really beneath
the surface realm as much as it's inside
of or between it the TVA could be inside
of or between the quantum realm of
pocket reality within the quantum realm
pocket reality where in this inner
Russian doll time does not exist hidden
behind a waypoint that only Janet knows
which might be that Dusty circular gate
that Janet is unlocking in the trailer
the way doctor strange and the
Illuminati created The Gap Junction in
Pocket reality to hide the book of
Ashanti Janet Van Dyne could have
created the null time zone pocket
reality to hide Miss minutes just
remember the name Miss minutes is a
secret pun Kang tells guy that he is
just a man who has lost a lot of time
like you and for one to lose time one
will by definition Miss minutes you can
follow me on Tick Tock Instagram and
Twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
And subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]